nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginé il ya 45 ans un petit garçon en
train de jouer à l'essai voitures les
voitures
j'ai toujours adoré ça ce tout confort
souvent de jouer sous forme de maquette
sous forme de bd ce genre de revue une
voiture en vrai aussi mais n'est plus
belle celle qui était à mes yeux les
plus désirables rester les voitures de
course quand j'étais gamin
voilà
quand j'étais gamin recomposer la
question ce que je voulais faire plus
tard je disais quand je serai grand je
voudrais gérard ducarouge chars
ducarouge vous ne savez certainement pas
qui c'est et c'était un ingénieur
français qui arrivait à faire gagner la
france dans toutes les grandes
disciplines du sport automobile en
formule 1 en endurance comme aux 24
heures du mans
et chaque fois ma mère me disait mais il
y en a combien déjà
karouf et j'ai veillé n'y a là qu'un
mais c'est de là que je veux être le
problème c'était études un peu à cause
des voitures toujours les voitures
encore les voitures en cours au lieu de
prendre des notes et de d'être attentif
à ce que nos professeurs nous ont
raconté
j'avais tendance à prendre crayon et à
dessiner dans les marges des cahiers des
engins improbable avec des ailerons
diverses des prises d'air improbables et
des moteurs gonflés
en gros tout ce qui m'intéressait
fonctionner avec quatre roues et un
moteur
les deux disciples et pour lequel
j'étais pas trop mauvais ça restait le
dessin et le sport le sport c'est du
tout sur une forme contemplative pour m
difficile avec un bagage comme celui-là
de suivre les traces de jean du cac
après avoir échoué deux années de suite
à mon baccalauréat
il me restait trois solutions
la première c'était de faire du dessin
la deuxième c'était de faire du dessin
et la troisième c'était de faire du
dessin
en conséquence je suis inscrit dans une
école de dessin je suis rentrée l'école
de penninghen en atelier préparatoire
et puis par miracle j'étais à tenir là
des supérieurs et là j'ai eu une espèce
de techniques d'espèces de révélations
où j'ai pris conscience que si je ne
m'étais pas à travailler si je ne sais
si c'est pas la chance qui m'était donné
j'avais probablement toutes les chances
de rater ma vie donc je me suis mis à
devenir une espèce de bête de travail ou
en l'espace de quelques semaines je suis
passé du cancre total au fayot le plus
absolu
donc des projets qu'ils étaient
présentes et il fallait absolument que
je les réussis s'il fallait absolument
que j'arrive à sortir de cette école
avec ce diplôme
et s'il fallait faire les dossiers une
fois deux fois cette fois sorti diplômé
je trouve un premier boulot en deuxième
un troisième est la même moment une de
mes tantes vient me voir et me demande
de lui donner un coup de main elle est
artiste peintre et participe à une
exposition qui s'appelle les proverbes
vu par les peintres
son choix s'est porté sur l'intro berne
qui s'intitule la fortune sourit aux
audacieux
vous imaginez la promesse la fortune
sourit aux audacieux
j'avais même entendu parler ce proverbe
et je peux vous assurer que c'était pour
moi une vraie révélation
et après 14 mois de salariat
relativement à satisfaisant
je décide à son malade de jus de mes
propres ailes de monter ma propre
entreprise et d'avoir ma propre
expérience professionnelle j'attends que
les petits métiers de transition de
remplacement et puis les premières
références je savoure les premiers
instants de boire mes références de
coucher sur papier glacé avoir mes
propres clients avant mes propres
projets j'ai je découvre à la chance de
travailler avec les premières grandes
marques mais je découvre aussi le
fait d'avoir des progressions
relativement chaotique des régularités
du travail l'agencé là elle fonctionne
mais elle fonctionne à la mode draft m
qu'est ce que j'appelle le bot caractère
c'est on fonce on freine enfonçons fred
l'activité est là les plus là les la
halle est plus là et là tout d'un coup
un jour patatras la banque m'appelle
déchets travaux photos viennent faut que
vous veniez nous voir
je me rends en avant et on annonce que
j'ai découvert de 50 mille francs
j'avais pas vu venir à l'époque
cinquante mille français et durant
cinquante mille euros de maintenant le
banquier regarde documents que je me
présente me donne trois jours pour
couvrir le découvert trois jours je suis
interdit bancaire trois jours où la
voile zite donc je rentre lagence ce
dépité je me mets à compter les tables
et chaises et donc les corbeilles à
papier inutile de vous dire
qu'évidemment j'arrive pas au bout des
cinquante mille francs même de l'époque
et là-bas hasard un peu plus
extraordinaire on sonne à ma porte est
un entrepreneur que j'avais fait
travailler quelques années auparavant
quelques mois encore auparavant vient me
voir en disant que j'étais dans le coin
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas vu qu
est ce que vous avez comme actualité
est-ce que vous avez pas quelque chose à
voir en ce moment et c'est bon je lui
raconte rapidement mon rendez vous du
matin et la chose incroyable improbable
le type et la main sa poche il sort son
carnet de chèques et il me fait un
chèque de 100 mille francs en disant
écoutez moi je crois en vous votre
banque et stupide allait déposer sa les
couvrir votre découvert mais vous pouvez
pas vous arrêter comme ça évidemment je
m'étais cuite
il y avait des problèmes de carburant
embrassèrent donc les affaires
reprennent reprennent de même assez jt
sous quinze jours trois semaines je
crois j'ai pu rembourser l'avant ce qui
m'avait fait face aux acomptes des
nouveaux contrats qui sont arrivés et
puis voilà
l'activité de lagence repart reprend
avec son activité de master ça avance ça
progresse et un jour de plus rien et
fier de cette première expérience je me
dis je peux absolument pas
donc un jour de plus rien c'est un jour
où vous arrivez au bureau et vous dit à
bas les affaires sont fini sa séance du
saas est un risque à faire et bien faire
donc vous dites je peux pas attendre
comme ça les mains dans les poches le
téléphone sonne
et ce jour là il y avait des bars du
paris dakar je décide de me rendre
départ du paris dakar
je ne sais absolument pas ce que je vais
faire mais j'y vais je dis c'est mieux
que dans le téléphone mais politiquement
keystone et donc je vais là-bas et je
décide de me promener au gré d alger
officieux des voitures de course quand
je ne sais absolument pas pourquoi je
sais pourquoi elles sont là mais je ne
sais pas pour presque et puisque j'ai
bien y faire et je me trouve à un moment
donné au détour d'une allée nez à nez on
va dire même mené contre calandre avec
un engin totalement improbable une deux
chevaux bimoteur une deux chevaux avec
un moteur à l'avant un moteur à
l'arrière
c'est un look de deux chevaux mais ça
roule comme une porsche
et là je
bon sang c'est un truc incroyable c'est
un truc
procter compte que c'est un des clients
avec lequel on travaille on réalise des
stands d'exposition pour eux au sein du
prêt-à-porter ont démarré ni de
franchise avec eux et il faut absolument
que je propose ce projet à coups de
coeur donc je me lance dans une esquisse
de projet et je commence avec mes
feutres et crayons et mon papier à
grouiller l'idée d'un design automobile
une voiture de course je cumulais
l'argumentaire que j'espère le plus
solide possible basé sur le contre
oubliez la communication de mener à
l'époque coup de coeur et j'appelle le
patron le pot ce grand téléphone
il accepte au rendez vous il reçoit et
la cour incroyable et si je signe j'y
vais on y va et là j'imagine et ma
position et mon sentiment je suis
évidemment totalement euphorique mais en
même temps que j'ai le veau riz du
passionné qui se met en route
j'ai aussi la conviction je tiens
quelque chose de différent quelque chose
qui va me permettre de différencier des
autres agences de design et qui va me
permettre de positionner
- entreprise de façon différente mais
aussi sympathique que tu sais de ce
projet j'ai besoin de quelque chose de
plus consistant et cette consistance jeu
l'imaginent au plus haut niveau
faut pas viser petit faut viser grand et
je décide d'essayer de prospecter et
d'aller voir des écuries de formule à
l'époque y en a trois l'écurie ligier et
que les narus et d'écuries à gs je fais
donc un ménisque en trois exemplaires et
la lecture guy larousse n'aurez-vous en
me disant écoutez votre projet nous
hanter
s on peut recevoir et je leur exposé
comment j'imagine organiser les marques
des différents partenaires sur 7 sur
l'homme pour leur écurie de formule
il m'a demandé de préparer un contrat
est de trouver dans un énorme embarras
parce que évidemment imaginez bien que
sa passion qui m'anime fait que j'ai
absolument envie de signer ce contrat
mais je n'ai aucune expérience du tank
le devoir est consacré et je suis
partagé entre l' angoisse d'être trop
cher et de voir le projet refusé et
l'envoi ce être pas assez cher et de ne
pas être crédible
donc ils viennent aider leur proposer un
partenariat un partenariat sur lequel
moi je vous rémunère sur la
communication que je vais faire autour
de 7,2 ce travail ait eu des différents
donc on travaille en termes de design et
puis ça marche
il accepte la voiture dessinée lancé on
présente aux ateliers et là je suis
chargé de la décoration et je me
retrouve le matin au petit matin au
moment où la voiture de course sort de
son de son camion pour pouvoir
travailler chez le peintre et avait côté
mais je n'avais pas qui se se pointer à
côté de moi pour voir le débarquement de
cette voiture
gérard ducarouge le jardin du gard où
jacky je voulais expliquer le job quand
j'ai
je me retrouve à travailler avec lui
pour le contacter est un peu géré il met
néanmoins correcte ils m'abordent mdi
bronze c'est toi qui es tu
des dizaines à bagnols en quelques
atomes est ce que ça mais dans les faits
c'est un peu ça donc on dépend la
voiture allait présenter la presse il
accueille de façon plutôt favorable et
jara vue carouge à la gentillesse de
vient me voir en disant qu' il trouve la
voiture plutôt pas trop mal
à partir de là va démarrer une
cheminement que j'avais espéré dès que
je n'imaginais pas aussi concret et les
annonceurs vont se succéder des arts aux
autres parce que villa du score c'est un
tout petit milieu où un partenaire en
côtoie un autre et qu'on ne travaillait
pas trop mal eh ben ça se sait plutôt
assez vite donc on va dossier dans
d'aiguilhe travailler sur des sujets de
photos de 24 heures du mans 2011
on va même retravaillé avec l'écurie
ligier qui devait refuser notre offre
quelques mois auparavant arrive 1987 et
en 96 je décide d'orienter mon
entreprise 100% dans le domaine du sport
c'est à dire que je veux que l'idée du
design dans sport soit une vraie
démarche stratégique et ne soit pas
perçue comme étant dit la démarche un
passionné ni une démarche opportuniste
en 98 avec les
championnats du monde la coupe du monde
de football on aborde plusieurs
disciplines jure nouvelle discipline le
bol et puis la voile le cyclisme
aujourd'hui quand on fait le bilan on
peut dire que les disciplines que je
maîtrise le mieux reste toujours le
sport et le design grâce à ces deux
disciplines
ça fait 25 ans que je mène cette
entreprise dans le domaine du sport et
qui me fait vivre de façon satisfaisante
est correct mais c'est aussi la
satisfaction d'avoir pu travailler dans
certains nombreux et pour un certain
nombre d'événements plus d'une
cinquantaine d'événements au travers le
monde d'avoir servi plus de 250 marques
d'avoir design et plus d'une centaine
d'équipés sportives
tout ça sur les plus grands événements
planétaires en 2010 pour vous donner un
exemple de voix le retentissement qu'on
peut constater j'ai des invités à la
finale de la coupe de france de football
arrivé en avance je me ces survivants et
puis bah évidemment par des formations
professionnelles je regarde un petit peu
ce qu'il ya autour de moi et puis je
m'aperçois que la corvée duo sûr
qu'elles sont alignés les marques
partenaires du stade de france c'est
nous qui les avons organisé je
m'aperçois que le logotype de la
fédération française de foot c'est nous
qui l'avons fait celui la coupe de
france de football
c'est nous aussi l'habillage graphique
de la compétition sort également de
lagence l'organisation visuelle des
partenaires qui sont sur les maillots
des équipes c'est aussi nous qui l'avons
fait et puis je me perçois des finances
des huit que tout ce qui est pour moi
finalement s'asseoir de la chance je
mets ça manque pour l'euro 2016
au printemps dernier on a eu la chance
de travailler avec le et femmes et
l'ensemble des compétitions
j'ai pu voir dans son dissident stand
des stades ont été habillées par la
chance ensemble des fans zone
les bus des équipes sportives et
beaucoup d'autres choses
en conclusion je voudrais vous dire que
si un jour vous avez des enfants vous
les voyez enfin crémation du travail et
on s'est peut-être ils sont en train de
créer leur propre métier
[Applaudissements]